the new M3 Max MacBooks are insanely
fast but they do have some annoying
issues that have been enough for people
to start returning them in cinch the M3
Max smoked the M2 Max and the M1 Max
which if you look the previous scores
were not that different compared to the
new one but at the same time the M2
Max's fans were barely spinning wow the
new MacBooks were going full blast and
even though in Logic the performance was
was mindblowing the fans were so loud
that it might not work for music
production if you're really pushing the
machine so I wanted to do some digging
and exploring and test out something
that I haven't looked at for a while and
that is the low power mode and let me
tell you guys my mind was blown what
this mode does to this new machine now
before I show you guys that I want to
talk about the high power mode as well
because with previous MacBooks it would
only make a difference if you're on
battery power and if you're maxing out
the CPU and GPU but I found something
that was very peculiar and that is when
I ran some tests on battery power we got
a score of
2,781 but then running it plugged in I
got a score of
2,389 which was noticeably higher so I
was thinking are we running into an
Intel situation where the machine
performs differently now well there are
some differences but what I found is
that the high power mode can actually
give you better performance when in the
past with the M2 Max and M1 Max it
wouldn't make a difference and with that
I had another Discovery these new M3
chips should run up to 4.05 GHz for
single core which is super high but
sometimes I would see that they would
only go up to 3.85 at a peak even in
geek bench right here it showed it as
that when I opened up the program
running a single core test in cine bench
I got up to 4.05 for the performance
core which is exactly what it's going to
need and then I tried it again but this
time it didn't go over 4 GHz at all and
it was running at about 3.8 for single
core even though our temperature is here
at the top we're running at about 70° C
now I Tred this both plugged and
unplugged high power mode or automatic
and what I discovered is it's not really
the high power mode that is helping this
it is actually just the temperature of
the whole machine and the chassis
there's some kind of a temperature limit
where it won't give you the full
4.05 unless your whole system is cool
and in this way these new Apple M3
series chips are acting kind of like
Intel chips where their maximum
advertised clock speed will only be
reached if the chip and the computer is
very cool and in a way that kind of
sucks sucks now with that I also noticed
this look at that section it says fans
turned off by Hardware I have not seen
this before where I'm trying to max out
the fans to cool down the system to
verify all of this but the system is
overriding what you want to do in TG fan
Pro and it doesn't let you now with that
would you believe that these new Macs
use more power than the old Intel I9
overheating MacBooks did I didn't
believe it either looking at this the
machine actually hit close to 60 watts
it actually ran at 58 Watts at Peak and
thermal throttled and slowed down here
and then kicked back up a little higher
and then slowed down again because even
with the fans maxing out there's just
not enough cooling for this much
performance the M2 Max maxed out at 39
watts and averaged about 36 compared to
averaging about 55 so that's way more
power that is required for this crazy
performance that it gives and another
way these new laptops are just like the
old Intel ones are that the fans ramp up
almost instantly after starting um which
is annoying but it's good for cooling
and with that the maximum we ever saw
was 102° C compared to 104 and with that
apple is preferring to run the chip
cooler here at 96° C but with the fans
completely maxed out instead of at 103°
C but with the fans running quieter and
that is resulting in an annoying loud
machine but one that is running a little
bit cooler overall and now let's dig
into low power mode and let me blow your
mind these new laptops are based off of
3 nanometer and some people said that
doesn't make that big of a difference
but in fact it's actually multiple
Generations newer than the M2 Max and
the M2 Max in low power mode gets
12,200 in geek bench 6 now that is not a
bad score but I I avoided using low
power mode because it didn't save that
much power at least previously the M2
Max ran at 2.7 GHz in low power mode and
didn't use that much of the efficiency
cores and with that two of the
performance cores were completely shut
off the M3 Max on the other hand uses
all of its cores even in low power mode
and it runs at 2.4 GHz per performance
and it absolutely hammers the efficiency
cores now and overall it's using 22
watts compared to to the average of 24
Watts with the M2 Max so it's using less
power and let me show you what
performance we get this thing got a
score of
16,720 low power mode but it even beats
out the M2 Max running at full
performance this is no joke guys we have
19% more performance than the fullon M2
Max and it even peaked at 26 Watts
compared to 36 WTS so we have % more
performance with about 30% less power
used so if you were thinking about
returning the M3 Max or not buying one
because of heat and fan noise well you
should think again this is going to get
crazier in cin bench for single core the
M2 Max uses 7.5 watts of power and runs
at about 3.4 GHz while the M3 Max runs
at 3.8 400 MHz faster and only uses 4
and 1/2 Watts of power so you would
expect the performance to be worse right
I mean we're using 40% less power but
nope we got a score of 139 compared to
120 that is 16% more performance while
using 40% less power and it gets even
crazier like I showed you before we're
using 22 watts compared to 24 and the
clock speed is at 2.4 GHz compared to
2.8 and the result is
1,77 compared to to
810 that is over 45% faster while using
less power as well and that is actually
29% faster than the fullon maximum
performance M2 Max and at the same time
this computer ran with the fans at the
slowest speed possible at only 90° celus
so it's staying cool completely silent
and still smoking the M2 Max by 29% so
if you are having second thoughts about
the M3 Max do not worry and do not buy
an M2 Max instead cuz you can get way
better temps and fan noise and way
better performance by just enabling that
low power mode setting and it is more
than fast enough now we talked about CPU
performance what about graphics
performance we were a bit disappointed
in the scores because the difference was
very small in our metal compute test and
with that the the M3 Max used quite a
bit more power as well but with low
power mode the M2 Max got a score of
124,000 peaking at 35 watts of power
that is almost the same power usage as
you normally would get but the M3 Max
scored 143,000 almost 144 peaking at
only 24 Watts that is a huge difference
in terms of power usage and at the same
time it is
16% more powerful as well so these new 3
NM cores even for graphics are very
impressive but wait till you see cine
bench here the M2 Max used an average of
20 watts and scored
5,4 whereas the M3 Max used an average
of 15 watts and scored
9,607 that means that it used 25% less
power but scored
85% more in terms of performance and I
think that is insane and the biggest
issue with these new M3 Max other than
the price tag of course uh is that they
run hot and they run loud but with that
said just using the L power mode doesn't
decrease performance a huge amount and
it still smokes the M2 machines while
running way cooler and way quieter so if
you haven't tested it out for yourselves
I would because these things run so well
in that mode so thank you guys for
watching let me know your thoughts down
in the comment section below click that
Circle above to subscribe check out that
video right over there this been Max and
I'll see you in the next
[Music]
one